In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 9th, on which we commemorate the Holy Hyromarter
Pancratios.
On the 9th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Hyromarter Pancratios, Bishop
of Tarmina.
Saint Pancratios was born in Antioch during the time of the earthly sojourn of our Lord Jesus
Christ.
His parents, having heard the Lord's miracles and teaching extoled, went with their young son
to Jerusalem and were baptized.
After their deaths, Pancratios renounced all that bound him to this transitory world and
went to the shore of the black sea, where he practiced askecies in a cave in order to
be aware of nothing but himself and God.
The Holy Apostle Peter, passing through the area to proclaim the gospel, encountered
the young ascetic and persuaded him to go with him on his travels.
Going to Antioch, Pancratios was consecrated bishop for the town of Tarmina in Sicily,
along with Marcian, another of the Apostles' disciples, who had come from Jerusalem and
who was ordained for Syracuse.
During sale for Sicily, Saint Pancratios converted the whole crew and also the captain, Lyconidas.
They arrived in Sicily after a pleasant voyage, and when the saints set foot on the shore,
the demons that were in an idol of the God Falcon, to which the people had to offer human
sacrifice every year, began to scream with terror.
The saint invoked the name of the Holy Trinity, raising as a staff the cross he was carrying
in his hand, and the demons immediately threw the statue into the sea.
Lyconidas, having recounted the miracles worked by Christ and his servants to Boniface, the
governor of the city, the latter summoned the bishop, but Pancratios asked that the governor
come to him.
Lyconidas fell on his face to the earth when he saw the glory surrounding the saint, and
he came to believe in Christ on hearing his preaching.
After having been instructed, along with his retinue throughout the night, the governor asked
Pancratios to go and bless his palace.
He was received with great honor and stayed for forty days, obtaining Boniface's authorization
to build a church in the city, the limits of which he traced himself.
The building was quickly finished, and at its consecration, all those present could see
an awe-inspiring fire descending and illuminating the entire church, and before the saint had
finished celebrating the divine liturgy, all the idols in the city were destroyed.
The pagan priests went yelling to the palace and reproached the governor for keeping feast
when such a catastrophe had struck the city.
Boniface succeeded in containing their agitation, and asked what the most learned among them
thought to be the reason for the idols falling to pieces.
Maybe some other more powerful God had appeared and cast them down.
Through the imprecations of one of the pagan priests, a demon called Lisan replied that
the God in three persons had rendered them powerless by the incarnation of the sun, him whom
the stranger brought by Lycanides had come and preached in the city of Taormina.
The idolaters remaining unmoved by this confession decided to sacrifice the governor himself as
a sign of expiation.
Saint Pancratios, warned by a terrified Boniface, spent the whole night in prayer in the church.
In the morning, they were preparing to emulate Boniface when Pancratios appeared, clothed in
his episcopal vestments, across in hand.
Boniface's bonds were loosed at once, and all the pagans present fell to the ground before
the radiance that emanated from the holy prelate.
Pancratios ordered the idol of Lisan to go and throw itself into the sea, and he killed
an enormous serpent that was feeding on the blood of the victims.
All then cried out, great is the God of Pancratios.
The great number of them were baptized, and the people who lived on the slopes of Etna
imitated them when they saw the healings accomplished by the saint.
A temple priestess, suffering from leprosy, was healed by the saint.
But when she uttered blasphemies, she was once again struck by this disease in a more serious
form.
Repenting, she received baptism under the name of Benedicta, and, after having been ordained
deaconess, went and broke up with her own hands, the idols that she had formerly served,
giving the gold to the poor.
As Boniface had to leave on a campaign with a vast army, he had his men blessed by the
saint, and a great many of the soldiers, on beholding the divine glory that surrounded
him, asked to receive baptism.
A cloud from heaven covered the saint during the liturgy that he then celebrated before
them, and a disappeared at the moment of the elevation of the holy gifts.
Boniface had left a certain alethas to replace him in the city, a callus and debauched pagan
who coveted one of the virgins consecrated to God by the saint.
After the mediation of a disciple of mountainous, he cast a spell on the young virgin, but
it was ineffective.
He then had the virgins arrested, and they, remaining inflexible under the pagan's pressure,
were beheaded.
St. Pancratios buried them in the presence of the people, and built a church in their honor.
As soon as Boniface returned to Tormina, he had elitist, punished, and encouraged the
building of churches all over Sicily, where disciples of St. Pancratios made many conversions.
Achilinos, king of Calabria, having besieged Tormina at the head of a powerful army, Pancratios
urged the people to place their hope in Christ, and even sent home the men who were manning
the ramparts.
He then climbed a promontory, armed with a cross and two icons, and blessed the city in
all four directions.
The enemy, seeing as it seemed three brilliant sons, fled, killing one another.
Some of them, however, gave themselves up, and, after having baptized them, the saint
sent them to Calabria to preach the good news.
During a new campaign of Bonifaces, his replacement Artagoras invited the bishop to a banquet,
in the course of which the saint threw down an idol that had been placed there.
The pagans then launched themselves on him.
He threw him to the ground, and beat him so violently that he gave up the ghost.
They then threw his body into a crevasse, where he was found by the faithful after anxious
searching.
Bonifaces, on his return from the war, punished those guilty, and had a golden sarcophagus
made to receive the body of the holy prelet.
Its saint Pancratios appeared to his disciple and successor Evagrius, to ask him to bury
in the bare earth him who had always despised gold.
During the funeral, his body appeared free of any wound and radiant with glory, and a delightful
fragrance spread around it.
A church was then built in honor of Saint Pancratios, disciple of the apostles and protector
of the city.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.